bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission dans laquelle nous gardons
sang-froid bonne humeur et bon sens à ce
qui n'est pas le cas de tout le monde
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons parler
du revenu universel bonjour estelle
bonjour olivier bonjour à tous bienvenue
dans ses cages c'était une proposition
de benoît hamon en 2017 lors de sa
candidature à la présidentielle
instaurer un revenu universel la crise
sanitaire actuelle semble avoir rouvert
ce débat l'assemblée nationale s'est
d'ailleurs prononcé fin novembre en
faveur de l'ouverture d'un débat
national sur un mécanisme de revenu
minimum universel auquel tout le monde
aurait lé droit
est ce une bonne idée quelles pistes
pourraient être envisagées on va en
parler
dans cette émission avec vous bien sûr
olivier et puis avec dany landais
économiste et membre des économistes
atterrés
ils sont 24 24 président socialiste de
département et il demande dès
aujourd'hui la création d'un revenu de
base pour pallier les effets de la crise
sanitaire
dans une lettre ouverte aux
parlementaires ils demandent des actes
plutôt qu'un débat
alors qu'est ce que l'on entend apa
revenu universel et quelle forme
pourrait tuer de prendre le point avec
le tiroir cash d'antoine baisse
c'était la pierre angulaire du programme
du candidat benoît hamon en 2017
on y pense et oublier disparu des radars
je suis pourtant la pandémie le ramène
sur le devant de la scène le revenu
universel ou revenu de base consisterait
à verser même somme d'argent à tous les
français sans prendre en compte les
besoins ou les ressources sans aucune
contrepartie il faut dire que les
chiffres sur la précarité donne froid
dans le dos 9,3 millions de français
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté est
potentiellement un million
supplémentaire à cause de la crise
et à la pandémie mais le rsa ou les
autres prestations me direz vous ça
existe déjà il y en a des aides dans
notre pays eh bien oui mais en france
toucher certaines prestations sociales
il est parfois un calvaire
bureaucratique entre une montagne de
paperasse et un défaut d'information sur
le sujet c'est bien simple on estime
qu'en france près d'un tiers des
personnes les plus démunies n'ont pas
recours aux aides auxquelles ils ont
légalement droit parfois simplement
parce qu'ils ne savent pas qu'elles
existent ou ne savent pas comment y
accéder
bref le revenu universel simplifierait
tout ce pataquès
reste le coût qui risque d'être salée
aujourd'hui déjà 30% du pib irait dans
les prestations sociales
alors imaginez avec le revenu universel
en finlande en tout cas l'expérience a
été tentée en 2017
deux mille chômeurs avait reçu 560 euros
chaque mois sans contrepartie cumulable
avec les allocations familiales et leurs
revenus s'ils trouver un travail
bilan de l'expérience une amélioration
du bien-être mais aucun effet sur
l'emploi
olivier le revenu universel et aux pieds
ou vraie solution face à la crise non
vraie bêtise comme d'habitude je dirais
mais vraie bêtise
c'est même pas tellement une bêtise je
pense que c'est une une forme de de
soviétisation de l'économie c'est-à-dire
que vous dépendrez entièrement de l'état
alors ça a l'air comme ça à sympathique
parce que on se dire bah oui finalement
on va donner de l'argent à tout le monde
donc mais si vous regardez ce qu'il ya
derrière comme intention ses gants quand
même beaucoup moins joli que la
présentation qu'on en fait quelles
intentions il ya derrière
c'est simplement que haut à partir du
moment où on rémunère tout le monde et
on prend la place d'un d'un travail
rémunéré
donc je vous dis on soviétisme
l'économie c'est l'état qui vous verse
votre salaire en gros et à ce moment là
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que vous
dépendez de la bonne volonté de l'état
donc vous êtes à son service et il en
fera ce qu'il voudra
c'est à dire qu'il pourra vous couper à
tout moment où maintenir sous pression
les le revenu en question croyez moi
vous allez avoir des entreprises qui
vont en profiter pour baisser évidemment
les salaires donc puisque vous toucherez
une autre partie par par l'état donc là
ça tombe bien on a le vide donc on sait
qu'on va avoir des millions de chômeurs
et et on arrive et on arrête on en
arrive avec cette solution qui est de
dire ben on va on va vous payer mais ce
qui m'inquiète c'est la contrepartie
tout ça et donc c'est toujours des c'est
toujours quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il
faut essayer d'envisager si vous voulez
y a rien n'y a rien de gratuit dans ce
bas monde malheureusement et donc
il faut se dire que s'ils font ça si
maintenant il en profite pour regarder
cette option là c'est qu'ils ont une
idée la tête et l'idée derrière la tête
c'est pas votre bonheur
merci au lion va revenir sur vos propos
dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec dany langue bonjour d'année langue
vous êtes économiste et membre des
économistes atterrés merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et bienvenue
dans ces caches bonjour merci alors dany
longue vous avez entendu les propos à
d'olivier en première partie olivier qui
parlait notamment de soviétisation vous
qu'elle est d'abord une réaction à ces
propos alors je suis d'accord et les
économistes atterrés en général sont
très divers mais ils sont d'accord pour
être opposé au revenu universel
par contre dire que c'est de la
soviétisation me paraît me paraît un peu
déplacé non il s'agit pas soviétisée
l'économie le revenu universel est une
idée qui a été avancée pour la première
fois par milton friedman qui était tout
sauf un économiste soviétique était
quelqu'un de libéral il ya un avantage
revenu universel qui a été soulignée
dans votre reportage qui est de
permettre finalement de résoudre ce
problème de nombreux cours de location
parce que les gens ne savent pas qu'ils
ont détroit où ils ont honte de demander
ces trois avec le revenu et recel n'y a
pas de problème de non recours le
problème du revenu et recel c'est
effectivement il y aura une contrepartie
c'est peut-être pas celle qu'envisage et
olivier delamarche parce que il faut pas
oublier vous avez souligné tout à
l'heure que c'était dans le programme de
benoît hamon mais c'était aussi une
proposition dans la primaire de la
droite de madame kosciusko morizet ou
c'est une proposition qui était dans le
programme de monsieur fillon
évidemment pas au même niveau évidemment
au pas aux mêmes conditions et la
contrepartie d'en parler olivier
delamarche la sustrac on va supprimer un
certain nombre d' aide et on va
supprimer
le rsa on va supprimer des apl on va
supprimer un certain nombre de choses
la contrepartie ça risque d'être ça et
donc c'est extrêmement dangereux parce
que finalement les 9,2 millions de
pauvres qu'on a dans ce pays vont être
encore plus pauvres et on parle donc
d'un tir des personnes les plus démunies
qui n'aurait pas recours au quai aux
aides auxquelles ils ont droit
finale est-ce que je remplace et
finalement le cn là comme le rsa par
exemple par un revenu universel est ce
que ça permettrait pas de s'amplifier de
simplifier les choses finalement à mon
avis c'est le seul bon argument pour le
revenu universel il dans la balance il
ya tous les autres c'est-à-dire la
suppression de toutes les autres aux
allocations il ya aussi des effets
inflationnistes sur les loyers d'une
telle mesure on a vu que quand les apl
ont été créées en france
les propriétaires en ont profité pour
augmenter des loyers il y a si on fait
un revenu universel en plus sans
supprimer les autres allocations
sociales
ça coûtait à peu près 450 milliards
d'euros c'est quand même considérable
donc personnellement comme tous les
intérêts pour les raisons que j'ai
évoquées
je suis opposé aux revenus ni à celle je
pense que c'est une idée séduisante sur
le papier ça résout le problème du non
recours mais ça ne résout pas le
problème de l'inflation
et puis ça coûte extrêmement cher par
rapport à d'autres mesures comme par
exemple l'emploi garanti dont on parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure olivier une
réaction mais je suis aussi atterré que
les économistes atterrés là dessus sur
cette proposition c'est ses normes et
ses 6 et 6 et remplacer un certain
nombre de mesures qui existent déjà les
remplacer par une mesure plus simples
qui permettraient à habas beaucoup
d'avoir accès d'avoir accès à ces assez
à cet argent très bien mais le problème
c'est que c'est pas ça le revenu
universel qu'on est en train d'essayer
de nous vendre le revenu universel qu'on
est en train d'essayer de nous vendre
c'est pas juste un remplacement de
plusieurs mesures en une seule c'est
c'est donner de l'argent à absolument
tout le monde
si j'ai bien combiné que moi sur le prêt
sur le principe
moi ça me gêne aussi parce qu'on
donnerait la même somme un sdf et puis à
monsieur pinault ou à monsieur bernard
arnault qui n'ont pas vraiment besoin
qu'on leur verse à revenu universel
l'idée du revenu à seul au départ
philosophiquement et y assez séduisant
qu'il faut le reconnaître c'est
reconnaître que parce qu'on est humain
on a des besoins et qu'il faut les
couvrir socialement
le problème c'est qu économiquement ça
coûte extrêmement cher et je ne suis pas
sûr de l'efficacité de cette mesure
aujourd'hui on a un france un dispositif
qui s'appelle territoire zéro chômeur ça
coûte pas très cher ça permet aux gens
d'avoir un emploi payé au salaire
minimum et ça leur permet de se
réintégrer dans la société et ça n'a pas
l'effet inflationniste aurait encore et
un revenu universel
cette piste là qui est une piste d'entre
eux garantis me paraît extrêmement plus
intéressante
et puis il faut pas oublier une chose
reconnaître qu'il faudra revenu
universel c'est aussi reconnaître qu'on
renonce au plein emploi
or moi en tant que keynésien je n'ai
jamais renoncé à l'idée qu'on peut
atteindre le plein emploi dans une
société démocratique est une société
libre d'aller langue dans la mesure où
l'on adapte ce revenu universel
donc il faudrait le conditionner et quel
serait selon vous le montant idéal
benoît hamon avancé l'idée de 750 euros
le conditionner non puisque un revenu
universel par définition n'est pas
conditionné le
le problème c'est de savoir si ça vient
s'ajouter aux prestations de dix tentes
ou si ça vient s'y substituer si ça
vient s'y ajouter
vous avez donné quelques chiffres tout à
l'heure moi l'estimation que j'avais
c'est 450 milliards en plus sachant que
le pic français est à peu près de 2000
mire donc c'est quand même c'est quand
même assez stratosphérique
par rapport à l'emploi garanti ou par
rapport à territoire zéro chômeur qui
coûte beaucoup beaucoup moins cher que
cette mesure et qui en même temps permet
un accès à l'emploi les personnes qui
proposent le revenu universel oublie
aussi un aspect important c'est que
l'emploi certes c'est une forme de
l'élimination mais en même temps c'est
une forme ça redonne la dignité aux
personnes alors que si on vous donne 400
500 euros en dix ans taisez vous ou même
750 euros maintenant soyez content cet
aspect là d'intégration sociale qui est
liée aux emplois disparaît complètement
dans le cadre du revenu universel
olivier ce qu'il veut ne faudrait-il pas
plutôt pencher vers une revalorisation
des prestations sociales par exemple on
met sur les jeux continuent sur ce que 1
dany langue nous disait sceller les c1
c'est un espèce de nivellement par le
bas c'est à dire tout le monde à 750
euros mais avait avec 750 euros vous
pouvez vivre non vous pouvez pas vivre
donc ça veut dire vous interromps 750
euros j'aimerais rappeler que c'est à
peu près à peu près le montant du rsa
couple voilà euros à 40 précédemment
pour un couple sans enfant
webb a essayé de vivre avec 826 euros
voilà vous loger avec 826 euros essayer
de pas dormir
dehors avec 826 euros enfin on est on
est là en train de discuter alors je je
je remercie dani lang d'avoir rappelé
que c'était friedman qui n'était pas
soviétique qui avait lancé cette idée
mais c'est quand même de la
soviétisation parce que vous attendez
tous finalement de l'état c'est à dire
que c'est l'état qui va vous verser vos
salaires c'est l'état qui va bientôt
avoir tout l'outil production parce
qu'il a tellement mis d'argent là depuis
les histoires qu vide pour sauver soi
disant l'économie que finalement les
moyens de production vont finir par lui
lui appartenir et donc on est en
malheureusement en pleine soviétisation
mais je le regrette mais sur la sueur le
sur le revenu sur ce revenu universel
pour moi c'est un espèce de nivellement
par le bas avec avec un revenu qui dont
les sur l'ailé les entreprises qui
auront des gens qui seront payés 750
euros croyez moi qui vont réduire les
salaires
évidemment on vous dit non pas crainte
également
effectivement comment feriez furent y
est vous avec un revenu universel et un
taux de chômage tel que celui qu'on a il
faut quand même rappeler qu'on est près
de 8 millions qu'ont à près de 8
millions de chômeurs catégories à b et c
c'est-à-dire quand on inclut les gens
qui travaillent partiellement et puis
les gens qui sont sortis des
statistiques parce que ça va trop mal ce
qu'on appelle les chômeurs découragés
là le taux de chômage que vous affichez
c'est le taux de chômage de catégorie a
il faut rappeler qu'on a tous ces
chômeurs donc effectivement c'est leur
donner simplement 750 balle ça me paraît
vraiment une mauvaise une mauvaise idée
et à mon avis il faut laisser le privé
faire son boulot pour les emplois qui
peut assurer laisser le public à son
travail pour les employés peu assurée
pour tous les chômeurs et bien leur
proposer un emploi payé par l'état mais
d localement c'est beaucoup moins cher
c'est beaucoup plus efficace et puis ça
permet aux personnes de retrouver une
dignité et de retrouver un accès à
l'emploi
messieurs avant de poursuivre on
remarquer une courte pause on revient
dans un instant bienvenue dans ses cages
si vous nous rejoignez au sommaire de
cette émission le revenu universel et
pour cela nous sommes en liaison avec un
damné langue est économiste et membre
des économistes atterrés
alors juste avant la coupure pure
olivier notamment vous nous parliez de
soviétisation pour autant le revenu
universel il n'a pas vocation à
remplacer l'emploi puisque certains
avancent même qui pourrait être cumulée
avec un salaire peut cumuler avec un
salaire qu est ce que ça va permettre ça
va permettre que je vous disais c'est à
dire que vous allez avoir des
entreprises qui vont vous dire ok vous
toucher 700 euros de l'état
donc moi je vais pas vous payer les deux
mille euros que je voulais vous payez je
vais vous en payez que 1301 donc
ça va permettre aux entreprises de
baisser les salaires ça c'est une
évidence et ça vous met quand même
quelque part dans l'est dans les mains
encore encore plus que la normale de
l'état qui vous procure votre revenu et
donc qui a qui a droit de vie ou de mort
sur vous enfin c'est il peut il peut en
faire ce qu'il veut il peut les monter
quand il veut il peut les baisser quand
il veut on est on est aux mains de
l'état et aujourd'hui je pense que
l'état a autre chose à faire que de
réfléchir sur le revenu universel avec
ce qui nous a faits depuis depuis 12
mois
j'aimerais bien qu'ils aient des
commissions qui s'occupe d'autre chose
plutôt que des de multiplication des
comités théodule pour s'occuper du
revenu university ont donné leur revenu
universel geste aux personnes les plus
démunies
c'est déjà ce qu'on fait à ce moment-là
qu'on simplifie mais à ce moment-là ça
s'appelle pas à revenu universel
s'appelle une aide pour des gens démunis
et la très bien et qu'on leur permette
plus facilement d'y avoir accès moi j'ai
aucun souci avec ça tant mieux il va en
falloir parce que là il va y avoir
beaucoup plus de personnes démunies
qu'il n'y en avait l'année dernière et
d'avant sur les chiffres du chômage dont
dany langue parlée à l'instant
on est on est là sur la même ligne c'est
à dire qu'on vous dit toujours on vous
parle de ce fameux chiffre de 9 % de 10%
qu'on va atteindre mais je vous rappelle
que c'est les chômeurs de catégorie a et
qu'aujourd'hui si vraiment vous cumulez
tous les chômeurs et les gens qui sont
sortis complètement qui sont sous le
radar est depuis un moment vous êtes
très probablement au-dessus de 20% et
non plus à 9
donc on olivier on est à 8 millions de
personnes
effectivement c'est dur à estimer mais
on a ces chômeurs découragés et puis on
allait bel essai y est c'est à dire les
gens qui ont travaillé partiellement
mais qui continue de chercher un emploi
à temps plein les baisser ceux qui ont
travaillé moins de 78 heures et se veut
laisser ceux qui ont travaillé plus de
mais ils sont là plus tous les chômeurs
découragés donc moi je maintiens que
c'est pas de la soviétisation mais que
ça faisait ça reste problématique
il faut se rappeler quand même on a le
rsa en france pour les plus pauvres
effectivement le problème c'est un
problème de nos mouvements recours à ce
rsa il n'est pas suffisant mais il
existe et l'autre problème du rsa c'est
qu'il n'est pas accessible aux personnes
de moins de 25 ans donc ça effectivement
au vu des taux de pauvreté au vu de la
multiplication de la précarité
il faudrait y réfléchir très sincèrement
mais c'est un autre problème et je suis
d'accord avec olivier delamarche
là dessus on est dans une situation
absolument préoccupante
à la suite de ce confinement la pire des
solutions maintenant c'est de mettre en
place ce soi-disant revenu universel si
vraiment on veut le faire ça va coûter
très cher et on va être obligé de geler
tous les loyers pendant un certain
nombre d'années
parce que sinon ça va se répercuter sur
les loyers on va être obligés d'imposer
aux entreprises de jeu les salaires
parce qu olivier delamarche a totalement
raison
les entreprises vont dire mais attend
des gestes plus la peine de payer 2000
euros les gens ils ont déjà droit à 700
euros
donc on va y aller on va les payer moins
ce serait une nouvelle fois une
subvention aux entreprises
or on a vu les
subventions massives moi je pense
contrairement à olivier pendant le coït
ça s'imposait mais on a vu avec le cce
ce que donnait ses subventions massives
c'est à dire il faut se rappeler que le
cce
il ya seulement un quart des entreprises
qui ont p qui ont utilisé la manne
nantel bénéficier pour créer des emplois
les trois quarts restants qui n'en avait
pas vraiment besoin on utilisait sa pour
les reverser leurs actionnaires ou même
pour virer des gens comme le secteur
bancaire voyez la piste donc le débat
son tour du revenu universel a été
ouvert en réponse comme une solution en
réponse à la crise à quelles autres
solutions vous paraîtrait plus cohérente
pour faire reculer la pauvreté
mais ça n'a jamais été une solution pour
pour ni sortir de la crise ni faire
reculer
c'est ben oui mais s'est toujours
présenté comme ça mais c'est de la
communication c'est à dire que on va
vous dire ah bah oui on vous a mis au
chômage parce que c'est la réalité c'est
ça on vous empêche de travailler on
bloque l'économie donc on vous a mis au
chômage
les responsables on les connaît c'est
les hommes politiques qui nous dirigent
ils nous ont bien chômage est arrivé ils
vont me dire ah mais rassurez vous on va
vous filer cette s'emballe excusez moi
enfin c'est pas c'est loin d'être une
solution et ses départements socialistes
que ce soit les départements socialistes
ou autre vous avez aujourd'hui ça n'est
absolument pas une réponse à ce qui
s'est passé avec le co vide le peuvent
ils nous a mis au chômage en grande
majorité et à amplifier le chômage parce
que il était déjà beaucoup plus haut que
ce qu'ont annoncé
donc il a amplifié les choses en plus
vous avez d une multitude de gens qui
qui étaient des entrepreneurs qui
étaient des des indépendants et qu'ils
n'avaient absolument pas les moyens de
se payer une assurance chômage et qui
eux vont sortir directement des radars
tout de suite sans passer par la case
chômage et donc
vous allez avoir dans le c'est pour ça
que je vous disais que l'année 2000 21
va être pour moi bien pire que l'année
2020 sur le sur la croissance et sur le
et sur le le chômage est donc là le
revenu universel
c'est évident que ça forcément on voit
on vous on vous attire avec avec des
arguments on affirmé à l'elysée mais
quelles autres solutions par exemple on
pourrait mettre en place à la place de
ce revenu universel pour faire reculer
la pauvreté que ce que disait dany
langue tout à l'heure c'est à dire des
mesures qui soient beaucoup plus ciblées
et qui ne coûtent pas 400 milliards en
plus les 400 milliards vous les êtes
vous aller les trouver où exactement
vraiment vous aller les trouver ou qui
va aller seul et sortir les 400
milliards pour faire un revenu universel
vous regardez on est on est on est déjà
avec une dette qui est colossal
on est avec un déficit budgétaire qui
est colossal
là on parle de 400 milliards mais 400
milliards c'est 20% du pib
on fait comment on les sort d'où c'est
l'abbé saura qui va nous les imprimer
encore dany l'environnement avant de
refermer cette émission il reste deux
minutes
quelle solution selon vous alors selon
moi il faut étendre le un dispositif qui
existe aujourd'hui s'appelle territoire
0 chômeurs de longue durée et ça coûte
18 mille euros par chômeur et par an
donc c'est assez raisonnable donc plutôt
que de laisser des gens au chômage par
en leur proposant d'emplois décidées
décidées localement en fonction des
besoins locaux et si possible en lien
avec la transition écologique c'est
beaucoup moins cher que le revenu
universel ça redonne un emploi ça
redonne une dignité l'assemblée
nationale pour l'instant daddy
territoire de cette sorte et c'est
réservé aux chômeurs de longue date
hermes
d'après moi il faudrait l'étendre
l'assemblée nationale a voté l'extension
à 50 territoire d'après moi il faudrait
l'étendre à l'ensemble du territoire
national donc on ferait quelque chose
qui ressemblerait à ce qui a été fait
par les états unis pendant la grande
dépression des
30 ça existe dans beaucoup d'autres pays
comme l'inde
l'ethiopie ses expérimentés en autriche
donc on redonne du travail à ces
personnes là qui en ont le plus besoin
et puis elles peuvent partir quand elles
veulent soit dans le privé soit dans le
public
donc on la remet le pied à l'étrier
juste pour terminer j'aimerais signaler
un ouvrage désintérêt le revenu
universel s'appelle faut-il un revenu
universel s'est désaltéré la fondation
copernic je ne suis pas l'un des auteurs
mais c'est un ouvrage qui reprend les
arguments qu'on a pu développer dans
cette émission et bien d'autres encore
merci merci beaucoup à damner lang
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et membre donc des
économistes atterrés olivier nous on
continue avec les questions cash et on
commence tout de suite avec la question
de nicolas imbert bonjour olivier quel
serait pour vous les solutions à mettre
en oeuvre pour sortir du système des
réserves fractionnaires convertibilité
avec un panier de matières premières il
en est assez d'un point de vue
économique et démocratique des dettes
pléthorique
alors je pense que malheureusement on
n'est pas sorti de ce système des dettes
pléthorique et on l'a bien vu là avec la
dernière phase avec le co vide
on ne fonctionne plus que là-dessus et
c'est général c'est à dire c'est
mondiale
mais bien sûr que une monnaie basée sur
de l'or ou sur un panier deux d'or
d'argent de platine de ce qu'on veut ce
serait
le propre le règlement du problème de
cette dette qui est de plus en plus
inimaginables deuxième et dernière
question olivier celle de jack 78
olivier quelles solutions concrètes face
à la multiplication des plans sociaux et
comment avis éviter les délocalisations
déguisée alors contre les plans sociaux
massifs cia il ya quelque chose d'assez
facile c'est laisser les entreprises
ouvrir parce que c'est les entreprises
qui créent l'emploi
donc si vous voulez faire mais il faut
pas s'étonner que elle licencie alors la
dernière émission on en a on en a parlé
c'est à dire que le coc vide a bon dos
le coc vide sert de prétexte à des
entreprises qui voulait dégraisser à le
faire et à le faire en disant non
comprenez la avec la situation dans
laquelle on est et je vous ai dit ça
n'est pas fini parce que le premier
trimestre et le deuxième trimestre 2000
ça va être encore pire alors comment
comment l'empêcher mais c'est ce que je
vous ai dit aussi dans la dans la
dernière émission c'est à dire que si
vous ne crée pas les conditions pour que
les entreprises reviennent c'est à dire
si vous changez pas ce qui les a fait
partir finalement et bien vous allez
continuer à avoir ce genre de choses
aujourd'hui aucun
finalement aucun jeune ne reste en
france ils vont tous faire leurs études
à l'étranger
ceux qui ont un cerveau donc
malheureusement si vous voulez vous la
main d'oeuvre disparaît la le
savoir-faire disparaît et donc ça va
être de plus en plus difficile de faire
revenir les entreprises sur le sol
français
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi au
prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant vous pouvez poser
continuer de poser toutes vos questions
à olivier sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag rtk choix en commentaire est
des vidéos et pour voir ou revoir nos
précédents numéros
rendez vous sur notre site internet à
l'adresse rt france point tv olivier
votre dernier mot mon dernier mot ça va
être ma petite liste au père noël
on a trouvé très vite un vaccin contre
le le coc vide
est-ce qu'on pourrait trouver un vaccin
contre la corruption et la bêtise parce
que je pense que ça peut être utile